hey what's up guys my name is a Cherno
and this is episode 102 of game
programming okay so this episode is
going to involve us tweaking the SRC
algorithm slightly as well as fixing
that little collision bug that we had so
if we launch our game in the current
state that it is in you can see that we
have a guy here with a mob that we
called star we've got the star mob that
utilizes the a-star search algorithm to
actually move around um and as you can
see follow us now why now he's good a
bit of a problem this guy if we go up
here let's just say he comes to us but
if we go around here fast enough you can
see he gets stuck on this little corner
okay and that's a result of the
collision area being slightly a bit too
big for him to get past so there's
simple way going around fixing this is
simply going into mob because of course
star is star is Ahmad right
and thus the collision for star is
inside the collision for mob which is
right over here
now mmm the very very simple tweak that
we can just apply is just tweet the
collision area so that it's slightly
less so if we change this 15 to a sixth
sorry if we change this 16 to a 15 here
for both the X and the y you'll be able
to say that uh he'll be able to get
around that corner no problem okay so
that's the very simple way of fixing
that now the other thing is he doesn't
really like diagonals okay this is gonna
be kind of shorter episode I just
realized but doesn't matter this uh this
guy's gonna um he's gonna kind of avoid
diagonals as much as he can and
logically so you can see that he goes
around he goes kind of if I just come up
here real quick he goes straight all the
time and then at the end he kind of
takes this day I don't root here and the
reason is doing that is because
obviously diagonals are let's just say
well they're worse than going straight
up right it takes you longer to go
diagonally and it's straight up
and the reason is of course if I crack
open paint on that real quick I'm sure
you guys already know the reason but
those of you don't the reason is because
if we draw a simple triangle here sorry
for my crappy drawing skills with the
mouse if we draw a a triangle here you
can see that going over here is going to
be about 1 going over here is going to
be scale of 1 and going over here
try doing all in one of these there you
go he's gonna be route to okay or
roughly roughly 1.41 that being said
this is the length of one that's length
one that's length of one point four one
mm so it's clearly a larger distance to
go diagonally and thus the a-star search
algorithm says okay well I'm not gonna
prefer that now that's really cool
okay and now that works but we aren't
some kind of GPS system that's trying to
find the most optimal path somewhere we
want this kind of kind of behave more
like a human and a human if we this guys
getting it this guy's like a pet or
something isn't it I should call them a
pair that's not a good idea
but um you can say that I'm by the way
the place that I shoot out is no I'm not
shooting for fun i'ma show you guys
something so I'm the place that I shoot
out if I'm trying to get to there and
I'm over here you know my instinct isn't
to go like this and then like that you
know my instinct is to go ahead and go
like this right so first move diagonally
then straight rather than move straight
as long as I can and then as you can see
at the end here move diagonally alright
so if I start over here I move oh no
guys I saw the chaser on us there we go
if I start over here and let's just say
I move a bit to the left I move up and
then a bit to the left or to the right
you can see that he moves at the end to
fix this or to kind of rewrite this a
style search I broke them in a way if we
go to level class into our find path
method which of course is our a-star
search algorithm if we go down here into
the costs we can tweak that and this is
where this is where some really cool
things come in right at the moment we've
got if something's solid then continue
you know if we add water the game which
we probably will run right once we add
water into the game I don't know realm
of does realm of does realm of the mad
God permit water going through water I
think so I don't know I think it slows
you down
it might anyway our water will probably
have some special features like you know
swimming and slowing you down and thus
being a larger cost to travel through
water
so we'll tweak the a-star special
algorithm to try and avoid it where it
can but not completely just ignore it
anyway the point of this is that these
two cost values can be cool
depending on circumstances to kind of
make the algorithm prefer certain things
right because it's going to find the
lowest-cost path so in other words what
we need to do is well where we get the
distance here essentially what we want
to do is say that cuz currently this is
what's happening right this get distance
is either returning one if it's that
kind of movement so in other words if
it's some not diagonal and if it is
diagonal is returning 1.41 okay roughly
it's returning the roof the square root
of two okay and that's if it's going day
if we're going diagonally okay so what
we want to do though is if we wanted to
prefer diagonals so we can just tweak
this to be something like zero point
nine four and nine five honestly it
doesn't really matter what it is in
between five in between 0.5 and zero
points I get well I'm in between 0.5 to
1 it's probably roughly going to be the
same if you put it lower than fourth
than 5 then 0.5 what it's gonna do is
it's gonna count two diagonals two
diagonals is going to be better or lower
cost than one straight which means that
your guy will actually you don't want
let's try that out we'll try that out as
well so I can show you guys the effect
but what will happen is you guy will
zigzag instead of going straight or
whatever he'll zigzag because diagonals
are better or at least he's getting the
impression that diagonals a better right
so to change this if we go into get
distance what we can do is get this
little thing that we're returning and
then conditionally return it right so
double distance equals that okay so and
then we can over here we can do
so if distance is if distance is greater
than one right then we can return in
fact if distance is equal to one it was
a distributive but return one I guess
otherwise we can return zero point nine
five for example so we might just change
this to be the other way around
just so it looks a bit nicer
all right so if you guys haven't seen
this kind of crazy question mark
notation by the way all this is saying
is what this what the product of this
will always be a number right and all
it's saying is taken to account beat
this boolean expression if this boolean
expression is true then that number is
0.95 otherwise or it's one else I guess
is like an else it's one okay so did
just to emphasize this as well it's
basically just a double okay so that
this whole equation returns a double
right it simply takes into account
there's a boolean expression again if
this boolean distance is greater than
one if that is true it will set s to be
zero point nine five otherwise if this
is false it will set s to be one it
should kind of just shorthand for
writing it okay and that'll just help us
a bit
all right so simple as that now what do
I just do I just opened
what do I even do it just hoping to help
whoops the welcome screen okay so if we
launch this okay so you check this out
right right now he's uh look at this
he's gone all crazy okay he's going all
crazy yeah you can see he's he's just
he's not moving straight at all so if we
go back to this we can tweak that let's
set us back to equals one so if it does
equal 1 we will return 1 otherwise we'll
return 0.95 okay so if we go back to
this oh no I still doing that okay
that's odd
let's say so if we come up here get
distance parrot oh yeah he's gonna do
that because of the age cost so we can't
simply do that the age cost this is the
other important thing the age cost which
is the heuristic cost that is kind of
the I guess the whole cost of him
getting from his current position to the
goal right the current position to the
goal or all like the tile that you're
considering to the goal and that has to
actually take into account the real
things we can't do it this way right
because it needs to know that tiles are
actually when they're diagonal they are
still you know greater so in other words
the the age cost component has to know
that diagonals are actually
1.41 whereas this doesn't so the easiest
way to do this it's gonna be really
simple instead of adding get distance we
can say that we can actually add get
distance right and if it's one sorry if
it's um let's see here if if it's if
it's one then one otherwise 0.95 all
right it's a bit of a bit of a twist
here right so what is going to do is
it's going to add it's gonna add either
one or point nine five if get distance
is one is gonna add it otherwise it's
gonna add zero point nine five okay so
if we run this we should see a much
cleaner kind of build so you can see
here moved straight away this time
instead of having to do it at the end
he's moving he's moving straight away
soon as I move he moves right you see
that here at here as well and that's
just a bit more human-like I guess he's
gonna look a bit more a bit more serious
here a bit more bit more determined so
you can see our guy now can pretty much
do anything he wants in the world he can
reach us if I go up here and hide behind
this little corner and camp here he's
gonna be able to come to us and kill us
so that's that's the idea okay
why collision needs to be fixed a bit as
well but that's a that's a rough tweak
anyway that's it all right so he can as
you can see that a style search
algorithm is working wonderfully he's
finding us wherever we are and not even
skipping a beat here look a
determination guys determination so then
anyway that's gonna wrap up probably
this series of a style videos
we're probably gonna start implementing
something like it like a GUI a that's a
graphical user interface for those of
you don't know something along the lines
of oh you know what let's make it okay
this is what we're probably gonna do
next episode we're probably gonna make a
mob that shoots projectiles at us okay
because I think that was quite a quite
requested and then after that we'll
probably start on some kind of inventory
and GUI system all right so um anyway
but do let me know what you guys want to
see I think you guys would want to see a
mob - who's projectiles at you that's a
relatively quick episode but we'll say
anyway thanks for watching guys if you
did enjoy the episode which I'm sure you
did cuz it was awesome please hit the
like button below and yeah also if you
go
need help this is I've probably
mentioned this because a lot of people
ask me this all the time if you guys
need help with with your code
something's gone wrong you're just not
quite getting it I do have a website it
is the Cherno comm slash forums right so
what you can do is you can go to that
and if you go to that they'll be a link
in the description of course there is a
massive forum here right if you go to
game programming because this is the
name of this series once you've
registered make sure you register first
right though not like you won't be able
to register in the actual forum register
on the actual website and then once you
log in and of course into the website go
to this form I'm going to get in
programming forum and making new topic
and I'll try and help you as best as I
can you can see that this community is
quite active so you'll be able to
probably find your your answer to your
question or your problem there so anyway
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
you